[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i'm jumping back on the bath
home and bandwagon
and we're going to go over some really
interesting games that were featured in
episode 4
of the queen's gambit i think they are
all from episode 4 tonight
uh episode 4 actually sees beth starting
well or continuing her professional
chess career by traveling to mexico city
for a big invitational tournament
there she for the first time faces off
against the world's best
instead of just the best players in the
united states so
there are going to be some mild spoilers
in tonight's episode of the road to 2000
but nothing that will spoil the whole
series for you uh
if you know if you didn't already know
beth harmon
is turning into a professional chess
player in the queen's gambit so that's
pretty much the extent of the spoilers
aside from a couple individual
really kind of inconsequential games um
so to start with
we have a game between one robert james
fisher
and ben larson there's a surprise i bet
you guys didn't know
they made an appearance in the queen's
gambit of course they actually
did not this is one of a series of games
in episode four where we just get brief
snapshots of
the chessboard during beth harmon's
tournament so
there's sort of kind of like a montage
where they just sort of go back and
forth between scenes and are showing
uh just brief clips of the chessboard
and
uh there's a lovely article on chess.com
that you all might want to check out
where somebody has gone through
meticulously and matched these all up to
the real life games that they
are taken from or at least derived from
and this is one of those games in that
short montage there are other games
in this episode that go into a bit more
detail but here i don't even think we
learn
the name of beth harmon's opponent we
sort of just see beth
playing a game and the position on the
board actually matches up to this bobby
fischer game
and it's a really interesting one so i
want to take a look at it here and
analyze this bobby fischer game
also seen in the queen's gambit so
jumping into it we have e4
c5 knight f3 d6 d4
take take knight f6 knight c3 and then
rather than the nightdorf or your knight
c6's
we're going to look at the dragon the
dragon variation of course not always
the highest reputation of all the
sicilian choices
but one of the most fun and you know
forever popular at the club level uh we
see bishop e3
by bobby which is one of uh which is
probably just the main move and dragon
players will all know that knight g4
is not a good idea in this position
because you lose two bishop b5 checks of
course
knight g4 the common idea to attack this
bishop on e3
say you're a fool for developing your
bishop out to this square where i can
easily attack it
uh you must save your bishop and move it
away which by the way
isn't even that bad either but white
does in fact just win here with the
awkward bishop b5 check
you legally cannot get out of check
except for blocking if you put a piece
on d7
then the problem is sort of exposed if
you put a piece on c6
well i'm i'm just going to take that and
this is a rather unfortunate situation
for you
even still even still so of course no
knight g4 just bishop p7
and now f3 for white solves the issue of
knight g4 before it ever really becomes
a problem
we see castles for black queen d2 for
whites
now knight c6 getting developed and
bishop c4
one of the most common ideas here for
white
sometimes white castles first sometimes
white just starts the g4
attack uh which is indicative of the
yugoslav attack but here bishop c4
and the idea of this move is to simply
keep a hold on the d5 square
make sure black isn't ever going to
break free with something like this
and oh by the way this bishop might be
responsible for a few threats a little
bit later on
uh bearing down on this f7 pawn and the
king behind it
on g8 that being said we're still well
within theory here and bent larson plays
knight takes d4 which is definitely not
the most common move these days bishop
d7
is far and away the most popular move
here just finishing development
and you know white is going to castle
and we're going to get
our normal yugoslav stuff instead though
knight takes d4
starts to take the game in a different
direction here
we see black taking off one set of
knights the bishop
comes out to d4 then we actually see
bishop e6
and it's pretty clear at this point that
black is taking a slightly more
conservative approach to this game
than you might expect from a dragon
rather than you know let white go all
out trying to check mate black and black
going for counter play on the queen side
we see here bent is sort of content to
take off some pieces
and get just a chest position the game
continues now with bishop b3
bishop takes e6 is a perfectly playable
move but at the end of the day
whenever you're building up your
opponent's center even if
it is at the expense of their pawn
structure
the central control is very often
worthwhile for example knight d5
is never really going to be a legitimate
threat that black has to worry about
here
so we see f takes e6 well sorry we don't
see f takes e6 we don't see bishop take
c6 because
that is perfectly fine for black and
said bishop back to b3 just keeps the
tension
in the position black now develops out
in
normal dragon style just queen out to a5
applying some pressure to the queen side
putting some pressure on this diagonal
and by the way the queen can actually
swing over to help defend some squares
on this side of the board
queenside castles by bobby sort of what
else at this point
and very importantly if you do take on
bishop takes b3
chatroom how should you take back a
takes or c takes really quickly what do
you think
a takes or c takes what's the point
what's the point here
so of course we are not going to play a
takes b3
when queen a1 check is not checkmate but
does force this knight back to an
awkward square
when black of course has fantastic
activity and a very clear path
to opening up another file but c takes
b3 is actually more than fine here
for white now rather than have pressure
against a pawn
down the c file and sort of total
control
over the half open c file white is
actually able to pretty comfortably
contest this file at a moment's notice
always able to play rook c1 here and
deal with any approaching threats
so good thing to notice here c takes b3
is very often a good change in structure
for white
in these dragon positions that being
said b5 is played and defensive
fans of ben feingold will always know
the next move here this queen on a5
is pressuring a2 we don't want to keep
our knight pin down to that forever
always play king b1 as ben says just to
free up the remainder of your pieces so
king b1
we see b4 now and we actually are still
very much in well shredded water
or well treaded on on a well shredded
path here
with numerous games reaching this
position white plays knight b
knight d5 sort of what else this is why
we played king b1
uh and black takes with the bishop and
now
bobby fischer sort of takes us off that
well-trodden road
by not capturing with e takes d5 so this
is
by far the most common move is e takes
d5 here and it's pretty easy to see
why the game has taken a rather uh
you know slow positional approach for a
dragon
for a yugoslav attack at least and now
white is going to be
looking to apply some pressure to this
backward pawn on e7
upon that's sort of annoying to defend
especially when this dark squid bishop
controls so much of the board
already uh instead though bobby plays
bishop takes d5 and this isn't really a
move
uh i understand to be honest with you i
don't really get it i don't know
why uh value fischer is playing bishop
takes here allowing knight takes d5
um there are a few games here though
that go bishop takes g7
knight takes c3 take take take take
take and those games all end in a draw
because
does white really have any advantage
here probably not
i think very technically if you count
the pawns white has an extra one
but of course this is not an extra pawn
that is
really worthwhile not not really upon
worth having
so maybe that's what bobby had in mind
maybe somehow
being down this pawn scared ben larson
but knight takes d5 actually wasn't
played and that's
gonna be the the first really key
mistake here of the game
you have to take this bishop onto e5
it's just such a powerful piece
if you don't take it then white controls
so many uh squares
and especially with your light squared
bishop off the board you're running out
of ways to deal with this pressure
against the king's side instead though
bent larson plays rook a to c8
and chatroom can you find the best move
here can you find the best move chat
wait to move here and maintain an
advantage
so mj says g4
gotta pay more attention to what i'm
saying mj i've basically told you the
answer
and yeah az lionheart has the right idea
here so of course
i just said black made a mistake you had
to take this bishop off the board
because it's such a powerful piece so
we're not going to give black a second
chance here
no reason to give black a second chance
at taking this bishop we just play
bishop back to b3
our bishop now cannot really ever be
captured
and we just have very comfortable
pressure on this diagonal pressure by
the
way
which really can't be alleviated by the
move e6 right this pawn on d6 is just
far too weak
and this doesn't really help black
whatsoever
by the way e6 doesn't really even
strengthen that many
uh strengthen the light squares that
well because once
these three pawns start getting broken
down the f-pawn is going to have to make
some tough decisions between defending
e6
and defending g6 whether that results in
a bishop takes e6 sacrifice
or just something taking on g6
it remains to be seen but notably e6
doesn't really strengthen black's
position at all
and it does leave this d6 pawn quite
weak
instead of that we actually see the move
rook c7 and i guess ben's idea
is just to get pressure down the c file
and finds
a queen side counter play before this
bishop can really make its presence felt
the problem here for bent is that white
is just going to be clearly better
this bishop is not only a great attacker
it's also a fantastic defender
basically before black can do anything
to get at this white king this bishop
somehow has to be removed and that's not
a process
that is going to be done very quickly
it's going to take a lot of time for
black to get rid of this bishop
and in the meantime bobby just launches
sort of a free attack
against the black king so chat room can
you find the idea now
how as bobby fisher do we take our
advantage with our super powerful minor
piece
and make it into something concrete how
do we develop an attack
from a position where we are
positionally better
mj says now g4
hello steve long time no see yeah we had
to cancel last week's road to 2000
unfortunately
we got snowed out we got snowed out
we didn't lose power or anything here in
st louis but we did get quite a bit of
snow
and uh had to deal with those effects
ah so some really good ideas in the chat
the first idea i'm seeing is g4 which is
the normal sort of yugoslav move
and that's sort of along the right track
although maybe not my preferred move
order here
and there was also the suggestion of a4
and i did want to highlight this move
and one other move like it so what's the
point of a4
well with a4 you were really trying to
make this bishop entirely unassailable
so a4 is a really sort of deep idea
so kudos to you guys if you came up with
it i don't know if it's quite correct
here but what's the point of a4 why
would we ever play a4
well the point is i just said black
needs to get rid of this bishop needs to
dislodge this bishop
before any sort of attack can really be
generated so how is black going to do
that
well black's next moves are probably
queen b5 a5 and a4 maybe with rook c8
thrown in there
for good measure so if you anticipate
queen b5 a5 a4 to get rid of this bishop
you can start arriving at moves like a4
as well just a move to really slow down
black's attack
now does it make the most sense in this
position i'm not so sure
so why does a4 the clever idea
not really work well it looks as though
black can actually apply some pressure
to this pawn
rather quickly and then instead of being
this huge
uh stopping piece on b3 this bishop is
actually not enough to defend
the advanced pawn on a4 it's much better
defending the pawn on a2 so a4 really
creative idea
kudos to you if you're coming up with it
but maybe not
the the best one here because again
knight d7 heading for v6 it does get
quite tough to defend this pawn
a3 is actually also another idea another
move that takes advantage of this pin
just to sort of you know win a pawn
almost by force here
uh forcing something like rp8 and then
uh
these are moves that black has to spend
that don't actually
develop this plan of a5 a4 however bobby
chose none of the above
with the other really great option uh
perhaps the best option which is just to
start
with h4 now why h4 instead of g4 well i
don't know
that it's critically important i think
g4 is also a very good move here
but the point is we're not really
worried about the move h5
what are we gonna do in response to the
move pawn to h5
uh this one if you play a lot of
sicilians will come pretty naturally to
you
i think so i'm not even going to pause
here if you want to try to find it pause
the video at home yourself but of course
the idea is just to play g4
you're just ripping open the files and
you're never really
worried about this you can even take um
f takes g i think but even stronger is
to just play h5
and then take you just take here knight
takes e4
queen f4 and yeah black is up a billion
pawns
but is quite clearly just going to be
getting kind of slaughtered here
unfortunately
for example if you try to save this
knight somehow let's say play a move
like d5 or something
simply rook takes h5 this has been cut
off this knight's attacked again
things get pretty bad pretty quickly if
you play some move like knight f6
g takes h5 is good g5 is also good rick
h5 is still coming
there's just no way to keep the king
safe after this move g4 so really useful
sacrifice to keep in mind
optically it looks like h5 really locks
everything down
but of course black just can't get away
with h5 here and by the way if you don't
take
well then i'm simply going to take on h5
reasonably quickly for example queen b5
i think i can take immediately but
perhaps it's better to to prepare it
even further
um something like bishop takes a f6
could even be considered with the point
being now
well okay there's actually queen takes
h5 here so maybe we should just take
and by the way don't forget we always
have this bishop on b3
to help dislodge any blockade of the
light squares
f4 f5 also going to be coming and it's
just a free attack
for white that's sort of the point here
what is a free attack well it's when you
get to attack the enemy king
and they don't really get to attack you
back and that's all down to having this
bishop on b3
black just never has any attack here and
white can
sort of rip open files at his leisure
so h4 is how we started now what would
be wrong with g4
well maybe it's just not quick enough
right we see that black's plan
is going to be coming through eventually
and if we play a move like g4 first
trying to prepare things maybe we're
just not getting there in time right
like h4
a5 h5 but then already a4 comes
and guess what our bishop is actually a
bit stuck
so important to start with h4 black
plays queen b5
going for the same type of counter play
then we see that it's going to be a
little bit too slow here
after the move h5 if black were to
continue now with a5
things get pretty rough pretty quickly
for example takes and if you play bishop
takes
queen h6 is a problem so then you have
to play this ugly move
and we can just start taking pawns
putting the bishop on d5
and white is clearly winning so instead
of all that we see ben to play the move
rook f to c8
uh fischer still takes on g6 we still
see takes on g6
uh and now what's the difference well
the difference is
that if we were to take here the ship
takes is fine because this is no longer
checkmate we moved the rook we have an
escape path
and the important move here for black is
actually the move e6
now check we have a ready-made
escape route available to us we have the
f7 pawn defended
and there's nothing really doing here
for white
so for those reasons bobby just uh
continues
the attack in the most natural way it
turns out the best move was actually the
kind of ridiculous
uh looking move rook h6 with the idea
being it attacks the pawn on g6 but
bobby didn't say didn't play that move
kept it simple and played the move g4
so now of course black continues with
the move a5
but as we see here thanks to bobby's
accurate move order
for seeing one more tempo from black
a5 a4 is coming just a single tempo too
late for bent larson here
bobby plays the move g5 and now after
knight to h5
white to move here chat room and i want
to point out it's one turn too late
because we play g5
now we have squares like the d5 square
and a4 is just going to be
a lot less potent of a threat in this
position
so white to move what can we do
finally g4 played yeah mj like your move
is is always
like it's never a bad move for white but
the question was
is it coming quickly enough in this case
and it's not because a5 a4 turns out to
be
you know while it is the only plan for
black it's not necessarily
a bad plan so the position called for
urgency which is what h4h5 did
and mj has the right idea here you can't
just let black
sit on this position with a knight on h5
and again if you if you play
the white side of these dragons long
enough you don't really even have to
think too much
about playing rick takes h5 here rick
takes h5
just fantastic move and the point of
this entire game so far
really has been this unopposed bishop
just white's looking to break down these
light squares
that's what h4h5 was about it's also
what g4 g5 was about
making this knight move off of its
defense of these weak light squares
now the knight has moved we're happy to
take this piece off the board
and the follow up of course is to play
pawn g6
again making use of this bishop on b3
now bent did put up a good fight here he
tried to move e5
to add some lateral defense bobby simply
takes on f7 now though
and after king f8 life is is getting
pretty scary here
for for black so
wait to move in this position uh what
should you do chat
what should you do and i'm kind of
layering i'm realizing that most of my
questions here have almost been trick
questions because sometimes the simple
move is just correct
yasser said once that whoever sacks the
exchange first in a benoni or a dragon
wins
yeah he's not entirely wrong not
entirely wrong
not entirely correct but not entirely
wrong
yeah parth has the right idea there's no
reason to get fancy
you don't need to play queen g5 or g1 or
anything although that may still win
uh bobby just says oh my my bishop's
attacked
i'll move it out of the way and the good
news for bobby is that this actually
comes with a pretty devastating threat
of bishop h6
and this is the threat that's going to
be ending the game for bent larson here
uh and also
beth's opponent in this series to bring
it back here once again
this is a game from the queen's gambit
uh we don't see it for long
in the show we just sort of get glimpses
but this is
taken from the show well actually the
show took it from
from bobby fischer i suppose so facing
down this threat of bishop h6 black
really needs to find some way to defend
the sixth rank
and the way that ben larson came up with
here is the move d5
and what's the point well the point now
is that if you play bishop h6
immediately
i'm going to take on f7 and if you take
the time
to take this pawn back well okay number
one this
hangs this but if you do something else
i can play something like queen a6 and
defend myself
hopefully so
bent just played the move d5 white to
move
how do we continue
probably shouldn't forget queen d6 check
two yeah queen d6 sorry this is also
also a big threat of bishop h3
or bishop e3
parts says queen d5 one two three four
four four four says rook g1
um and okay i'm not going to lie to you
here
white's position is pretty good rook g1
probably wins
queen takes d5 is probably not such a
great move uh
you don't need to be trading queens with
your opponent's king
so so weak but bobby finds the best move
in the position
which is e takes d5 and the reason this
move is so strong
is because now uh black has a weak king
and also by the way this pawn is
promoting pretty quickly
like it's it's not a long path to to the
d8 square
and the pawn is already well supported
by white's major pieces so e takes d5
a great great move here showing that you
know bobby doesn't really need to put
his eggs all into one basket here and
this is what happens
when you get sort of a quote-unquote
unquote free attack so bobby of course
did sacrifice the exchange
but that's not very much at all to give
up for this kind of attack on the black
king
and because bobby hasn't really given up
like a full piece or anything like that
he has a lot of pawns for the exchange
already
that means at any moment you should be
willing to
just sort of play chess again right and
that's part of what bobby's doing here
and you see this in a lot of bobby's
games where
he has sort of this free attack but but
also like he doesn't mind winning by
promoting a pawn either like
what's the harm in that so just
compounding the problems that ben is
facing in the position
uh ben larson does get to take off this
f7 pawn now
but d6 is quite simple once again
unleashing this bishop
on b3 and inching this pawn closer
rook f6 is what bent larson chose in the
game but now the simple move is bishop
g5
notably though rook f6 was kind of
forced if you come back this way
once again bishop h6 is going to be very
very powerful
so rook f6 bishop g5 uh bent larsen
plays queen b7
trying to defend laterally and willing
to give up the bishop
and then for some reason in the show
they decided to switch the move orders
here
in the show we see beth play the move d7
which is good uh it leads to force
checkmate but in the game
bobby played bishop takes f6 which
actually also leads to force checkmate
perhaps a couple moves a couple moves
faster even
so we'll stick with this game for now uh
bishop takes f6
bent of course just takes back and now
we do see this move d7
rook d8 and the last move of the game is
queen d6 check
when ben larson decided okay that's
enough
i resign of course king g7
spent my met by rook d1 check
and the game is not going to last
too much longer here
so bent resigns after queen d6 uh
in the show they show that d7 check is
played first
then beth takes on f6 and then we see
queen d6 check with
with the same result in the exact same
position in the end
so again uh probably in the show this
takes
about 10 seconds of time for them to
show this game
but it's such a fun game i wanted to
show it to you guys anyways
um again so this shows up in the mexico
city tournament
uh i i guess it's maybe called the
mexico city invitational it's definitely
an invitational in mexico city
in the show uh which was of course
fictional
but the real game is bobby fischer v ben
larson
and it's a game worth knowing a lot of
instructive stuff here
uh showing you what can happen with just
one really powerful
minor piece this bishop made all the
difference in the game
and then the powerful past pawn in the
end bringing home the victory
so this unopposed bishop gave bobby a
free attack
and bobby fischer with the free attack
is going to win the game
more often than not so i'm going to open
up two questions here on this game
before i move on
to another one
why not queen d7 get the queen's not a
great blocker but the pawn needed to be
stopped
well yeah uh at this point in time
the the improvements aren't really going
to be um
aren't going to be too meaningful here
um so why not
why not queen d7 instead of queen b7 i
it probably doesn't make a difference we
probably still take this guy
and then honestly like this move is good
uh
probably the reason why queen b7 was
played is to stop queen d5 here
with this idea if i had to guess spent
larson's thinking
this seems pretty reasonable but like
any move wins like g1 wins
this move wins and this move wins it
it's all bad at this point
what website is that we are on lead
chess tonight
well let us move along then so i wanted
to show
a game that gets a little bit more air
time in the show
so next up i want to show you this game
between beth harmon
a chess prodigy in the show i don't
remember his name sorry i did a little
bit of research for this
but the names are tough i don't remember
the fictional character's name
but in the show there's this uh adorable
little russian boy
who wants to go to american drive-ins
and see movies
and he's a bit of a prodigy in this show
that's how he's sort of introduced
so beth is up against a prodigy in this
tournament as well
and we do get to see a lot more of this
game in the show
and it actually almost exactly follows
this draw
between dimitri yakovanko and daniel
stellwagen
and it's interesting that they selected
this game it really goes to show
how much work was put into the uh into
selecting these games for the show
because they didn't follow the game
exactly which ended in
a draw in the show they actually
introduced
an improvement to the chess game so not
only did they just find famous chess
games or really interesting chess games
but they found chess games that ended in
the draw and
improved upon them on the show showing
that beth harmon transcends
mere you know copying of the chess
legends
she improves upon their games so let's
jump into it here we've got jakovenko
against stalwagen
and we have another sicilian defense net
f3 e6 and by the way beth has whites
a prodigy child from russia who has a
name that i
will not remember has black d4
c takes c knight takes d knight c6
uh so a little bit of a different line
here we see
uh a paulson variation actually with
black playing e6 rather than g6 or d6
and just knight c6 going for a more
light squared centric
approach we see knight c3 now d6 by
by black and this is sort of a structure
that is quite common in in sicilians
you'll see this
very very often black doesn't advance
either pawn out to the fifth rank
um of course in the night or if you see
e5 in this case
these two pawns sitting on the sixth
sort of for the moment rather cagely
just defending all of the squares on the
fifth rank
uh bishop e3 for white is fairly normal
and again
i just want to mention whenever you play
this move with white you should be on
the lookout for a move like knight g4
in the dragon it was unplayable because
of the check here it's unplayable
because the knight can't move twice in a
row but after knight f6
we see that this is something that needs
to be well i guess it doesn't need to be
addressed because we have that that
square defended
um but just to show you the two main
moves here bishop e2
and f3 both very much with the idea of
making sure knight to g4
never gets played in the game we see
beth take a different approach
with the move f4 so who knows what f4
is indicating here it indicates one of
two main plans really what do you think
beth
or yakovanko was getting at with this
move f4 in the sicilian
ah it's gyorgy i'm assuming that's
pronounced gyorgy the chat to my rescue
i don't think it's georgie i don't think
that's how russians say the letter g
but uh gyorgy sounds about right
steve north says o-o-o
without the hyphens i assume he means
queen-side castles but
uh i'm looking for something a little
bit more direct than that
what is the idea of f4
because there's one really common idea
and one sort of less common idea but
it's important for black to keep both in
mind
protecting the e5 square no room for the
black
knight so i uh i mean i i can agree that
you know 95 isn't playable anymore but
that's not really the main point of this
idea
of f4 of course you know vaguely it's
preparing some sort of push
on the king's side everybody can kind of
agree with that but
the move i really want to highlight is
this move f5
this is something that has to be on
black's mind whenever you see this move
f4 sort of appearing on the board so why
does f5 matter
well f5 is probably actually a pretty
bad move
if you know black were to just play
something like bishop b7 we shouldn't
really be playing f5 here
encouraging this move e5 because once
we've done that we've sort of revealed
our hand to black
right away but something that's white
could consider doing
is a move like bishop c4 now i think the
main theory goes something like queen f3
but let's stick with bishop c4 for a
moment then let's say black castles
bishop back to b3 and something like a6
for example now with this bishop on b3
as we saw in the bobby fischer game
it applies a lot of pressure to the
light squares
for black and definitely now f5 is going
to be an idea to look out for
because that is the move white can
always employ to just rip
open the light squares entirely start
fighting for the d5 square
start fighting for sacrifices on f7 and
on the king side in general and
that's the main pawn break i wanted to
to highlight for you guys now
is white ever thinking about playing e5
sort of rarely
yes but for the moment i think f5 is the
break to look out for
and then this idea of just controlling
the e5 square it does come in handy
quite often
as sometimes you'll see you know these
g4 g5 kind of kinds of pushes as well
so that's what you should be thinking
about when you see this move f4
it's not always just like oh you know
white wants to control
this square or whatever it's it's
usually more direct than that
if you see it in combination with bishop
c4 especially
white is looking to break down these
light squares and if you see this pawn
staying here
it's often used as a lever to support g4
g5 so some really important ideas to
keep in mind
going forward now uh georgie is not
going to
you know take this lying down he plays
the move e5
right away so there's a couple ideas
here that
white can employ the two main moves by
far
are going to be f takes e5 or knight
back to f3
so what's the downside of f takes e5
well the game is going to take
a bit of a slower approach can actually
just take back with black
and probably trade the queens or
something like knight g for
aiming for the square more directly so
beth
plays the move knight f3 instead keeping
things alive
now what's that move i said you always
have to look out for it whenever you
play bishop e3
of course that move is knight g4 and now
it's playable
because our knight is in the way of our
queen attacking this square and perhaps
this is why
f4 is not the most common move these
kinds of ideas
can very readily appear so what's the
big idea what are we going to do about
knight g4
well beth and yakovanko were actually
just intending
to give up this bishop with the move
queen d2 allowing knight e3
queen e3 ef4 and queen f4
so i want to get the chat room's feel
for this position we saw in the previous
game
black gave up one of the bishops sort of
with a disastrous effect
right bobby fischer's extra light
squared bishop was the decider of the
last game
it gave bobby a free attack and sort of
completely limited and hampered black's
attack
so is the dark squared bishop going to
be equally valuable
in this case what do you guys think yes
or no
steve says lines where queen f3 is
played to support the puns so yeah
talking about that f4 move queen f3 is
very very common to support the pawns
but it's it's also with the idea of you
know advancing them later on stuff like
g4 g5 i think is
common with the the queen g3 move
so yeah everybody's saying no or just
one person's saying no over and over
again
um fair enough great wolf says i suppose
that black can manage
g6 and bishop g7 somehow so that's
that's
sort of it right we would love to put
this bishop on the long open diagonal
sort of matching what a bishop on b3
might look like for white
um you know attacking the black king
defending the white king presuming it
castles king's side
that'd be great but unfortunately that's
just not very realistic here the bishop
is needed
to help guard the d6 pawn if you play g6
for example queenside castles
and you already can't play the move that
you wanted to play because d6 is just
going to be hanging
so yes time is a huge factor and because
of that time
black can't really effectively activate
this bishop there's just no good way to
do it
for example bishop b7 was played in the
game and white
uh just queen side castles and once
again this bishop is not really that
useful of a piece
sitting here on e7 just passively
defending this weak pawn
on d6 that being said the two bishops
are two bishops
and white is going to have to be very
careful to make sure that this bishop's
potential
doesn't ever get actualized
to use a word that i vaguely understand
the meaning of
so that's going to be a huge feature of
this game making sure this bishop on e7
doesn't become the monster piece that
bobby fischer's bishop was
in a previous game we see bishop e6 in
this case
and now knight d5 of course white
looking to utilize this square
part of the benefit of giving up the
dark squared bishop is increased control
over the light squares right so white
making use of that here
we see kingside castles and always play
king b1
says ben feingold rook c8 now for black
and now we reach another decision point
for white we sort of got castled got our
king to be one
now we need to start making some
decisions on the best way
to approach this this middle game i
think it's safe to say we're pretty well
out of the opening
at this juncture so what's going to be
important in this middle game i already
sort of gave you a hint
this bishop is going to be important we
need to make sure this bishop
stays on lockdown doesn't get activated
but of course
other things are going to be important
as well so what is white looking to do
well kings are on opposite sides it's a
sicilian
we should probably be finding some way
to go after the black king
and of course we also want to keep the
pressure up
against this pawn on e7 so with those
things in mind
uh jakovanko and beth harmon continue
with the move
g4 and at this point this knight on d5
is sort of just too too strong to be
dealt with
to be left alone for any longer
so bishop takes d5 is played now we get
rook takes d5
knight b4 attacking many things rook d2
defending one thing and now the move
queen b6 so for the moment
black seems to have finished development
despite being down
a little bit in that time in the opening
we still have the problem of this bishop
looking a little bit silly
but you know the future is maybe not so
dim for this bishop right bishop
f6 looks like a great uh great threat
for black to start thinking about
so white to move here a chat what are we
going to do
and med and aminag amine
libremi tough name has
a great idea in the chat
and yeah it's the move g5 so g4 g5 is
the really great idea that i wanted to
highlight in this early middle game
white understands the danger of giving
up the dark squared bishop
so early on if this bishop gets active
black is going to have a great position
and so white simply says i'm not letting
it get active i'm not letting this
bishop
get to f6 i'm not letting it control e5
i'm not letting it attack my king
i'm gonna play g4 g5 yes with the idea
of pressuring the king
but even more directly with the idea of
keeping this bishop from getting active
so g4
g5 great stuff by iakovenko
and fictional character beth harmon um
in the game we see
rook c5 as the continuation applying a
little bit of pressure here
in simply a3 by white kicking this
knight back away
to c6 the game now continues with the
move h4
but as opposed to the bobby fischer game
where bobby had a free attack
with a great light squared bishop
defending all the squares on the queen
side
here it's definitely not a free attack
for white black is making very concrete
threats on this side of the board
and once again a lot of latent potential
for this bishop
on on e7 threatening to come to f6 and
really rip some things open
so with that in mind black is
immediately making threats
so white plays rick d3 to defend
we see black uh retreat back with rook
to b5
sort of shuffling and making threats one
after the other and now
white plays the move queen c1 and for
the moment everything seems to be under
control
so unable to make any more immediate
threats uh black simply brings more
pieces into the game with rook c8
and let me ask you guys at home if you
can predict
black's next two moves based on the move
rook c8
i wonder if you can i wonder if you can
what do you think black's idea is
with rook c8 it might not be what you
expect
ah and we've got gm beth harmon in the
chat room who is offended at being
called fictional
tough tough
here all i'm saying is last time i
checked
anna joy taylor great actress
no chess titles as far as i know no
chess titles i could be wrong
maybe fiji gave her some type of
honorary gm or maybe
in secret she's been training for years
for this role but as far as i know no
chess titles
um and schaaf has sort of the intuitive
idea
right black put the rook on c8 of course
black is looking to play something like
knight a5
get the rook into the game and start you
know continue attacking on the queen's
side
but uyghur has an even better idea
with the move bishop f8 and the point
here
is that black once again is looking to
realize this bishop's full potential
trying to get it on this long open
diagonal
and use it in the attack and to defend
the king at the same time
so rook c8 is actually very dangerous
yes because it puts more pieces
uh in front of the white king but also
because it threatens
to utilize this uh this bishop which for
the moment has been sad
but is always sort of lurking in the
shadows waiting for the right
opportunity
to become a very active piece all right
continuing the game though
we see bishop e2 and surprise surprise
black's next move is bishop f8
trying to enact this idea okay how to
continue now
so the f file is half open so white
decides to put this rook on f1
and of course now we see the move g6 for
black
so how should we deal with this bishop
coming to g7 let's see if you can find
uh what beth harmon played and what
jakovenko played and
if you can find what the best move is
because we'll give you a hint they're
not the same thing
they're not the same thing here
wow i'm hearing unconfirmed reports in
the chat that beth harmon is making an
appearance on pogchamps or maybe they
mean anna joy taylor
could be other one
so let's see if you guys can find the
best move
and what white played in the game
i am the worst ever i knew i was saying
something wrong it's not
anna joy taylor it's anya taylor joy
all right god everybody's gonna be so
mad at me i'm so sorry
please forgive me huge fan of the show
by the way
huge fan
oh god that's that's pretty tough huh
okay
everybody has a billion different ideas
so the point i want to get across here
is sometimes the best move isn't the
move that the grand masters want to play
so what do i mean by that well if you're
a human being
and most of us are not all of us but
most of us um
you're terrified okay i'm terrified here
look at this bishop oh my god
my king is gonna die this bishop's
coming to g7
what am i gonna do am i gonna play like
c3 and hope that that keeps the bishop
at bay like i'm pinned on this file
there's gonna be some sacrifice there's
knights coming into b3 coming into c4
i don't want this i don't want this if
i'm a human being playing with the white
pieces now that being said
computers are pretty good and computers
are going to say wait a second i just
play c3 and the bishop's like worthless
and you don't really have any concrete
threats like sure i weaken some squares
but i'm going to check me two in the
meantime with like h5
um and that's what computers say so c3
technically the best move in this
position the the idea with h5 is the
same you just have to respond to bishop
g7
with c3 uh and i i think
white is is doing well here although
maybe you do have to be a bit more
precise
um with this move rather than playing h5
first so
c3 is the computer move but the move
that beth harmon played in yakivenko
played
might be very counter-intuitive to us
lowly
non-gm players but i think it is
a very intuitive move to a lot of grand
masters and i might be wrong on that
not being a grandmaster myself but you
know being a human being who has been
checkmated
many many times by powerful bishops i'm
like i need
some concrete way to stop this bishop
from murdering me
and what white played in the game is
rook b3 now unfortunately this does give
up
white's advantage white was doing a bit
better off thanks to
some accurate opening play keeping this
bishop sort of tamed but then
the moment to sort of let it loose was
right here with c3
and instead yakivanka was scared
yaakovanko was scared he said let's
let's trade off these pieces
and maybe life will be a bit better
so this move isn't as bad as it looks it
looks for the moment like you're totally
blundering all your pieces right
but the idea here is bishop c4 and the
point now
is that it's black's turn to be very
very afraid
right it's black's turn to be a bit
afraid here with the rook on f1 coming
in handy and this bishop activating
while uh there might not be any
immediate knockout punches
this does look quite scary so with all
that in mind we see black actually
playing rook c7 here which is again
a very human idea so we do get our pawns
doubled but white is going to live to
tell the tale with queen b1
now how did this effectively stop this
bishop from being a problem
well it alleviated all the pressure down
the b file in anticipation of this
bishop landing on g7
so now we have pretty much an equal
position right black's pieces are
now useful in doing something but not so
useful
that white is just getting checkmated
the game continues now with bishop c4
we see knight d4 by black jumping in to
hit the pawn on b3 uh and we're gonna
see the simple trade
by white we see take on d4 queen takes
d4
uh beth chooses to keep the queens on
the board for a moment with queen e2
queen takes d4 is also okay but again
maybe a bit premature
uh with this pawn on b3 and this bishop
now being a superstar defender
white doesn't really have any issues
with the king and there are still some
questions left to answer
if you're playing with the black pieces
about this f7 pawn
in particular uh the game continues now
with rook e7 perhaps highlighting that
bishop d5 would be a bad move now
rook f2 perhaps saying wait a second i
kind of wanted to play bishop d5 i'm
going to defend my queen
and then we get a very forcing line with
rook e4
bishop f7 king h8
and queen c2 so trading the center pawn
for this f
pawn what's the downside for black while
black loses some shelter around the king
the upside you get a big pass d-pawn for
the coming end game
uh we're gonna continue now with rookie
one check king a2
and now quincy eight is a pretty pretty
big threat only threatening checkmate
just a little bit checkmate so we see
queen c5 by black
and now after b4 queen c2 and rook c2 we
have
ourselves an end game so of course who
should be better
in this end game uh
anya joy taylor
taylor joy dang it god ah
or uh you know gyorgy and
i'm never going to know what actor plays
gyorgy nor do i really want to know
child actor number 37 with russian
accent
white because beth is playing white and
a couple people in the chat do dare to
say black
with uh i assume the idea being this d
pawn
has no other pawns in front of it which
is scary i admit
so end games are about many things and
past pawns are one of those things
however while this pawn is technically
passed it's also on the sixth rank
or third rank from black's perspective i
guess meaning it's got a long way to go
and it's got a pretty difficult path to
get there you're gonna have to cross
some light squares and in any position
with bishops of opposite colors
especially with at least one other piece
on the board
the the past pawns don't always advance
quite as quickly
right i cannot control the d5 square as
black and i can control it as white on
top of that
the king safety can become a real uh
real real issue here so with opposite
colored bishops
often times the most important thing is
piece activity and that's actually true
for most end games
even more important than the material
sometimes even more important than past
pawns is just how active your pieces are
so here white is going to be better
because this rook is very active
it's very difficult for black to
actually deal with uh with the threats
in the position
to start black plays the move bishop e5
making room for the king so
black doesn't get immediately checkmated
and now we see white playing
bishop d5 which actually again is
threatening
a checkmate in two to combat this we see
h6 from black
rook c8 check by white king h7
we get one more check in king h8
and now chat room can you find beth
harmon's brilliancy
this is the improvement over the actual
chess game
played by yakuvenko against uh
stel stalwagen this is the improvement
beth harmon white pieces can you
find the way the path to victory
and this is going to be a pretty tough
one
too tough for yakovanko he's pretty good
at chess
but not too tough for beth harmon
and i should say this is a little bit of
added drama
in the series at this point uh as you
can see this game
is a bit longer than bobby's game
against ben larson we're on move 40 here
and in accordance with uh i think
adjournment rules
at the time maybe they did it a move or
early in the show
white's 40th move is actually getting
sealed here
so beth harmon and gyorgy were agreeing
to an adjoinment
and beth had to seal this next move
which turns out to be the critical move
now in real life i think white actually
plays the 40th move and black seals the
move
maybe no maybe it is this way i don't
know maybe it is this way
and yeah you guys actually have the the
red idea here
with h5 so yakivenko being a huge passer
said i'm gonna take all the free pawns
and then win like this
but it turns out that that's actually
not quite good enough black gets counter
play with rookie
gets to take on b2 with check and then
after rook d2
bishop has to move and we see the pawns
start to disappear from the board
this pawn is not going to be long for
this world if you were to take on g6
guess what no real way to defend this
pawn
play rick b5 go bishop e5 and you're not
taking this guy
so you're not going to get any extra
pass pawns over here
and at the end of the day rook d7 was
played
and to fast forward a little bit we see
that white does have a 2v1 majority
on the queen side
turns that into a 1v0 majority
but this is not going to be enough to
win worst case scenario
black sacrifices this bishop for the
pawn and rook
in bishop vs rook should be a draw and i
think we actually do get there
in the game no we don't rook b6 check
and in the game was agreed
just to be a draw so what was beth
harmon's improvement
not rook takes b7 of course but instead
the killer move
h5 and now this is obviously like a very
optically pleasing move
but it's not immediately obvious how it
works
so generally how this works is black
takes one pawn and you take the other
right that's just sort of common sense
right you're not going to lose a pawn
because black takes one pawn and you
take the other that's not quite the idea
here
the idea here for white is you can
actually create a mating threat
using one of these pawns so no matter
which pawn black takes
white is actually aiming to play the
move g6
so if g takes h5 we're not playing g
takes h6 with a more or less even
position
instead we're playing the move b7 or g6
i don't know where b7 came from the idea
is rook h7
is actually checkmate and this is the
move
that really is going to give georgie a
pretty tough time here so
h5 a massive winning idea here for beth
harmon
and i think from this point forward we
don't see too much of the board
until the very end of the game so i'll
just show you sort of an example
continuation
there's really only one move here for
black
this is just awful you just are getting
checkmated you have to give up a piece
right away
and this move is a bit better but still
pretty bad because again you're
well i guess it's not even a bit better
you still just have to give up this
bishop
and by the way you don't even
immediately get this this guy like i can
even just keep this
which is quite sad uh
so the the only real move for black here
is to go with rook e2
the idea being you're pressuring b2 and
actually there's a
very sneaky defensive idea that black
has to find in order to just
not immediately get checkmated and that
idea is that after a move like a4
making a space for the king otherwise
rook b2 is at least enough for a draw
probably just winning with a
discovered attack but a4 rook b2
king a3 only move and then black to move
here
and stay in the game of course is the
move rook
h2 with the incredible incredible idea
being
you know i defended h7 look at me i
found a way to do it look at me go
and of course we needed to come to the
second ring to do this because rook h1
is bad for this reason
now of course though this is going to
lose the b7 pawn and this is sort of
where i
stopped my analysis white is going to
basically just win this game
compared to the previous game because
now black has to deal with these threats
on the queen side creating a past pawn
and also has to make sure
you don't get checkmated immediately
right so for example if you commit to
trying to stop this pawn
you're going to run into this idea where
it takes g6
and then these passers are sort of too
strong and if you don't commit to taking
that pawn play something like bishop
here
well now i am going to sort of stop this
pawn
if you play rook h6 i think there
is a bit of a tactic here with g7
and more checkmating ideas and
there's just no way out here for black
really now judging
by the end position that they do show in
the game i'm assuming something like
rick takes h6
was the idea for what happened we saw
something like
takes takes i think this pawn makes it
to a5
i'm just going to assume something like
rook g7 i'm sort of just making this up
off the cuff here
just trying to kind of recreate the end
position
this king ended up over here or
something
and in some position like this uh we see
yorkie tip is tip is king over and
resign i remember seeing this this
pawn here this this bishop around and
why does gorgeous resign well two pawns
versus zero is a lot different than one
pawn versus zero you're never going to
be able to sacrifice this bishop for
both of these pawns
and white's just going to push one at a
time one after the other
until the queen is made and
the way they they show this in the show
is is rather funny uh
beth harmon of course uh seals the move
h5 and then goes back to the hotel room
and as they do
in real life and also in the show she's
sort of analyzing in her head i think
she actually sets up the position on the
board as well
and so the next day she comes back to to
the board
and sort of uh seemingly has it all
worked out which is pretty impressive
because there were some
complicated tactics left left to work
out there but
she plays the move and then in true
obnoxious chess player fashion
this is one thing they got right about
chess players when they know they're
winning they are rather obnoxious
she plays the move and she gets up and
walks away and is looking around
you know yorgi makes the move and she
just immediately comes back and plays a
response it's the clock and
gets up again like why are you wasting
my time you should be resigning what are
we doing here
and uh i found that to be quite
entertaining there's
parts of this show that they do really
well as far as just the demeanor of
chess players
and sort of they they kind of nailed the
smugness
of knowing you have a winning position
here knowing you played a brilliant move
in
h5 and knowing your opponent is is
resigning in a matter of moves so
really fun stuff i'm enjoying going over
games from this series
i thought i was gonna go over up to like
five games tonight but these were such
rich games that we only got to two
let me know what you think if you guys
want to follow up maybe i'll do
some of the other games from this
episode maybe i'll keep going
later it all depends on what you guys
want to see
that is going to do it for us tonight
though as always my name is caleb denby
i want to thank you very much for
watching tonight's edition of the road
to 2000.
i will see you next tuesday at 6 30.
have a good night everybody
[Music]
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the twenty thousand square foot
expansion and upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space
in 2021 when we will host the 2021 u.s
chess championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
you